lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
considerar bajo qué condiciones una
distribución muestral de proporciones se
ven aproximadamente como una normal y
bajo qué condiciones se ve como una
distribución asimétrica a la derecha es
decir algo así y bajo qué condiciones se
ve como una distribución asimétrica a la
izquierda es decir a algo así las
condiciones que vamos a mencionar en
este vídeo y esta es una regla básica de
aproximación van a depender de que si al
multiplicar el tamaño de la muestra por
la proporción de la población que nos
interesa es mayor o igual a 10 y además
si al multiplicar el tamaño de la
muestra por 1 - p es también mayor o
igual a 10 si ambas cosas se cumplen la
regla básica nos dice que podemos
aproximar la distribución a una
distribución normal
es decir la distribución muestral de
proporciones se ven aproximadamente como
una normal así que con esto en mente
hagamos un par de ejemplos por aquí y
tengo este de aquí emilia maneja un
restaurante que recibe un pedido de 50
mandarinas cada día según el proveedor
aproximadamente el 12% de la población
de mandarinas está demasiado madura
considera que emilia calcula diariamente
la proporción de mandarinas demasiado
maduras de su muestra de 50 mandarinas
además podemos suponer que la afirmación
del proveedor es correcta y que las
mandarinas diarias representan una
muestra aleatoria cuál es la forma de la
distribución muestral de la proporción
diaria de mandarinas demasiado maduras
pausa el vídeo piensa un poco en lo que
acabamos de decir e intenta resolverlo
primero observa que tenemos muestras
aleatorias de 50 mandarinas así que para
este ejemplo en particular
va a valer 50 por otra parte la
proporción de la población que está
demasiado madura es del 12% así que me
vale 0.12 muy bien entonces si
multiplicamos a n por p voy a obtener 50
por punto 12 ok y cuánto es esto
bueno 100 por punto 12 es 12 entonces 50
por punto 12 es 6
esto es menor o igual a 10
inmediatamente rompemos la primera
condición y ya con ello podemos concluir
que no podemos aproximar esta
distribución a una distribución normal
ahora la pregunta será para qué lado es
asimétrica y la clave es recordar que la
media de las proporciones o la media de
la distribución muestral de las
proporciones diarias es igual a la
proporción de la población que está
demasiado madura que como ya dijimos es
del 12% si lo dibujamos por aquí voy a
tener este par de ejes por aquí voy a
tener el 50% por acá tengo el 100 por
ciento y nuestra media estarán aquí en
el 12% por lo tanto vamos a tener un
valor máximo por aquí y después va a ser
asimétrica a la derecha como una grande
larga col
de modo que éstas eran asimétrica a la
derecha muy bien hagamos otro ejemplo de
acuerdo con la encuesta de ernesto la
radio llega al 88% de los niños cada
semana considera que tomamos nuestras
aleatorias semanales con n igual a 125
niños de la población y que se estima la
proporción de niños radioescuchas en
cada muestra cuál es la forma de la
distribución muestral de la proporción
semanal de niños radioescuchas bien
pausa el vídeo e intenta descubrirlo
en esta ocasión tenemos una n de 125 lo
podemos ver justo aquí 125 niños y la
proporción de los niños radioescuchas es
del 88 por ciento es decir en esta
ocasión pp vale el 88% 0.88 entonces
observemos n por p es lo mismo que 125
que multiplican a 0.88 y esto en
definitiva va a ser mayor que 10 porque
esto es más grande que 100 y esto es
casi el 90%
así que sin duda esto es mayor o igual a
10 y por lo tanto cumplimos esta primera
condición ahora que hay de la segunda
condición bueno vamos a ver cuántos n
que multiplica a 1 - p
y esto me queda 125 que multiplica a 1.8
lo cual es 0.12 y bueno observa esto
también es mayor que 10 el 10% de 125 es
12.5 entonces el 12% es sin duda mayor o
igual a 10 no es necesario calcular el
resultado solamente con estimar lo bien
por lo tanto también cumplimos esta
segunda condición esta vez aunque
nuestra proporción de la población es
muy grande observa es cercana a 1 se
cumplen ambas condiciones ya que nuestra
muestra es muy grande y ya podemos decir
que la distribución muestral es
aproximadamente una distribución normal
para tener una mejor intuición veamos
qué es lo que pasa por acá si por aquí
tenemos el 50% y por acá tenemos el 100
por ciento y nuestra media estará en
0.88 muy cercano a 1 esto para nuestra
distribución muestral de proporciones
así que por aquí va a estar nuestra
media
y si tuviéramos una muestra más pequeña
nuestra desviación estándar estaría más
alta por lo que terminaría con una
distribución asimétrica a la izquierda
pero en este caso como nuestra muestra
es más grande tenemos una desviación
estándar más pequeña para nuestra
distribución muestral lo que hace que se
apriete la desviación estándar y esto
hace que se vea más como una
distribución normal es decir se parece a
una normal por lo que podemos
seleccionar aproximadamente normal como
la opción correcta ya que cumple las
condiciones de esta regla básica si te
preguntas si es perfectamente una normal
la respuesta es no de hecho si no
tuviéramos esta regla básica y la
dibujáramos a mano tal vez podrías
pensar que tiene una cola más larga
hacia la izquierda pero si usamos esta
regla que es una regla estándar en
estadística y usamos este límite
entonces podemos concluir que esta
distribución tiene un
de forma aproximada de una distribución
normal muy bien entonces nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo